[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous
[Musique]
plus pour la première du festival de
cannes série un festival qui a duré une
semaine ce soir c'est la clôture on va
remettre les prix je suis très content
d'être ici je m'appelle kyan khojandi je
suis un grand fan de séries gens mangent
énormément elles font clairement partie
de ma vie
on a d'ailleurs voulu faire une
cérémonie à la hauteur des séries
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire grandiose
créative et pleine de rebondissements
on aimerait que chaque personne ici ce
soir repartent avec un souvenir
inoubliable mêmes donc un show novateur
clairement à l'américaine j'aime importe
quoi qui font les petites instant forte
encore une excuse et je veux savoir ce
qui t'arrive qu'est ce qui se passe mon
pote je peux plus le faire quoi et
pourquoi grandiose créative à
l'américaine mais vraiment non mais tu
mets la barre beaucoup trop mon pote ça
me fait flipper mois mais ne t'inquiète
pas et puis tu peux pas planter comme ça
je suis en plein direct sur canal
salut mes rivaux j'ai besoin de toi mais
cros et si toi faisons un truc simple
attend un peu mon amour je réglais ça
tout de suite et je suis à toi dans une
minute enfin qui tu parles à une femme
que j'ai rencontrée aux toilettes ce que
tu te fais des meufs sans moi maintenant
oui tu t'es pas chez toi
bon tu sabilité oui eh bien tu fais ça
et tout va bien se passer
ok ok d'accord coule donc un show
novateur à l'américaine j'aimerais que
ça explose dans tous les sens
vous aimerez vraiment que chaque
personne il ya qu est-ce qui fait mais
mais non mais mon micro non mais non
mais y avait moi la paix à la fin
excusez moi c'est ce qu'on appelle les
élèves du direct pardon oui
les séries sont à l'honneur ce soir des
grandes séries aujourd'hui les scieries
sont devenues un phénomène à part
notamment de par le casting
les grands acteurs des grandes actrices
grand réalisateur romain grange les
doigts pour la cérémonie c'est allé trop
loin tu vas le payer
allez viens à me battre tiens tiens bon
cheryl est tombé ça va être compliqué
pour ce soir rabhi toi j'ai un truc à
gérer à vous les mecs avec vos petites
guerres d'ego c'est toujours pareil pour
moi je te laisse je vais terrible soirée
entre filles
tu veux dire une soirée à la sex and the
city non à la plaque
wright a fini c'est maintenant je suis à
toi va et vient battre
salut mon pote
[Musique]
salut mec comment on fait pour arrêter
de tomber j'en sais rien voir je tombe
depuis huit saisons
[Musique]
voilà c'est réglé pour l'ombre je suis
vraiment désolé pour cet abattoir
excusez moi voilà juste au dessus je
récupère mon micro
sinon je pourrai pas continuer la
cérémonie fut de m'excuser vraiment
arrangé
qui va me le payer mon pote
[Musique]
on a maintenant oui
concert de quoi on a survécu à un crash
d'avion
c'est vraiment un miracle on est vivant
ouais bilan je veux pas trop pessimiste
dégâts mais attendons 128 épisodes pour
être bien sûr c'est bien fait et j'ai
même envie de savoir la suite pas vrai
j'ai pas que ça à [ __ ] moi allez salut
mon pote eh ben il est beau le roi de la
colombie qui part en plus comme une
petite fille de 11 ans c'est trop mignon
[Musique]
au fusil non mais t'es un vrai petit et
de repos ok d'accord tu veux la jouer
comme ça très bien mais pas un attrape
store
[Musique]
ça a été calme et assez bon c'est bon
qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu fumes commence
à winter is coming banon né en avril
puis déjà steve et on a eu deux
centimètres de neige c'était la coopaq
l'apocalypse dans toute la france n'a
pas envie que ça recommence commence à
winter is coming et je viens de prendre
des vacances je veux quand même pas
appelé mais 200 minute perdue c'est toi
qui vas me le payer
ouais bah t'es pas obligée de payer tout
va vraiment être ok d'accord
c'est quoi ça c'est dégueulasse mais bon
c'est réglé ok c'est bon isolant drolet
on va pouvoir gauck et ils sont vraiment
trop nombreux mais heureusement que j'ai
toujours sur moi ma lampe de poche
[Musique]
jack harris
notre gueule les gars
bienvenue au festival quatre séries
vénissieux
[Applaudissements]